if you watch the show yesterday listen
to the show yesterday I started it off
in kind of a weird way right I said hey
let's pretend for a second that there's
no Russia story we have this whole new
scandal which was that Donald Trump's
campaign consultants Cambridge analytic
ah were totally exposed by Britain's
channel 4 as admitting that they used
the tactics of blackmail hiring
prostitutes for entrapment and honey
traps bribes and the dissemination an
arguably creation of fake news and it's
Cambridge analytic of Cambridge UK the
company's top executive is alexander nix
and he personally as well as others were
caught on camera in what is just a
brilliant investigation by channel 4 in
the UK and the question now it's not
really whether Trump worked with a truly
depraved company here but rather how bad
was the stuff that Cambridge analytic
Adid for Donald Trump and part two of
this investigation or I guess really
it's kind of part three it's the second
part we're talking about but I think in
total it's part three anyway it doesn't
matter a subsequent part of this
investigation by channel 4 has now aired
and it's linking Trump directly to these
people who are claiming this is their
assertion that they handled everything
for Donald Trump's digital 2016 campaign
and this is becoming a major major
problem for Donald Trump and I want to
look at some of the clips I just love
good investigative work and this is
right up there this is some great stuff
here is one clip where you have
Alexander Nicks saying that he's met
Trump many times that they ran the whole
thing for Trump and even taking credit
in a different segment I think it might
be mark Turnbull taking credit for how
Trump was able to win despite losing the
popular vote by millions they are
targeting presumably with some of that
ill-gotten Facebook data of course the
reason why we would assume from
was able to do that if indeed you
believe the digital targeting excuse me
was responsible or to blame for that win
here's clip number one take a look have
you many times when you think about the
fact that Donald Trump lost the popular
vote by three million votes but won the
electoral college fee that's down to the
data and the research if you did your
rallies in the right locations you move
more people out in those key swing
states on Election Day that's how he won
the election he run by 40,000 votes in
three states
yeah the brand was defeated
I mean zeros the OCO of crooked work
pair of hanger and it was all about like
business she belongs behind and you look
created then we made creative hundreds
of different kinds of creative not
exactly coffee boys right I mean as far
as they're saying directly involved in
some of the key elements of what if you
believe this is how Trump won got Trump
over the finish line here's another clip
of Alexander Knicks this is the top guy
at Cambridge analytic ah explaining that
the way they work they deliberately keep
the candidate out of the loop the
candidate is effectively an uninformed
puppet and I was thinking as I watch
this yeah that actually does ring a bell
sounds like somebody we know right let's
check out the second clip can't against
the puppet so if the US people ask you
are you working for these people you
also know we don't know
none of your business I have to speak to
them if the Republicans ask three
questions yeah
Alexander Nix who has now been suspended
by Cambridge analytic I was later
confronted on the street by channel 4
reporters and I just love this stuff mr.
Nate's Channel 4 News have you ever used
entrapment in the class because that's
what you appear to be offering our
undercover reporter appearances can be
deceptive
and then as I mentioned Alexander nicks
has been suspended by Cambridge analytic
and once again these statements that are
being put out by the company are just
laughable they're now trying to paint
the picture they just had no idea that
any of this stuff was going on when this
is what they do right Cambridge analytic
upon a statement where they said the
board of Cambridge analytic AHA's
announced today that it is suspended CEO
Alexander Knicks with immediate effect
pending a full independent investigation
in the view of the board mr. Nyx's
recent comments secretly recorded by
channel 4 and other allegations do not
represent the values or operations of
the firm and his suspension reflects the
seriousness with which we view this
could the statement be any less
believable Alexander Knicks as the CEO
of Cambridge analytic ah represents the
exact values and activities of the firm
he's getting suspended because he got
caught not because he was acting in some
way not consistent with what it is that
our Cambridge analytic --is core
business practices on a regular basis
who believes that Cambridge analytic ah
has been doing this all over the world
with glee from higher-ups up to and
including the CEO and just nobody knew
the board didn't know nobody had any
idea that this is the type of stuff that
Cambridge analytic a does that this is
what they are hired to do these are
liars of the
absurd kind I would call them Trump like
Liars that's the type of lying that this
is so the questions now are are these
ethical actors that's not a question
anymore that's been answered right the
question did Trump work with these
people that's been answered at this
point we knew about that now the
questions that remain are number one did
Cambridge analytic I participate or
conduct illegal activity when they were
working for then candidate Donald Trump
did the Cambridge analytic influence
campaign operate totally separately from
Russia or were they working in concert
that is another question that we have
and this is just extraordinary
journalism and about a year ago you
might remember this entire Cambridge
analytical thing sort of started to
surface right like we first heard the
name Cambridge analytic about a year ago
and it was written off by the right
basically as a conspiracy theory and
those rightists who acknowledge that
maybe there was something there with
Cambridge analytic ah were using it as a
way to attack Hillary Clinton and or
Barack Obama and yet one year later here
we are and the really important thing is
you don't want to get tricked into
thinking that these are all minor
unrelated stories right I mentioned we
don't know if Cambridge analytic ah is
directly connected to Russia but we know
about the connection between trumps
former very close advisor and chief
strategist Steven Bannon holding a stake
in Cambridge analytic ah we know about
the connection between the Facebook data
of 50 million users and Cambridge
analytic Ambridge analytic admits that
they were using that data or at least
some data which we can guess is that
ill-gotten Facebook data for these
campaigns we know about Russian hacking
of the DNC and attempts to perpetrate
the voting systems of 21 States at least
one of which was done successfully and
we know about some of that leaked
information hacked information
from Russia being leaked through an
intermediary to Julian Assange and
WikiLeaks for publication and of course
it comes full circle with Julian Assange
being in touch directly with Donald
Trump so the pieces individually are all
coming to the surface and we're
identifying more and more connections we
don't yet know what the finished puzzle
looks like but we've got a lot of the
pieces and we're starting to put
together the edges if I'm gonna carry
the puzzle analogy to its logical
conclusion yeah and after this channel
for news report we know that these guys
aren't masterminds because they're
oversharing they're bragging too much so
if there is any criminality there any
connections to the Russia investigation
I think Muller would find that out yeah
I don't know to what extent molar is
directly looking at those particular
connections but you would hope that this
is going to become I I would presume an
important part of of Mueller's
investigation and this now is bigger
than molar right that's the truth
because you've got the FTC and British
politicians investigating Facebook for
the data piece the data that ended up in
the hands of Cambridge analytic a you
have an investigation in Britain of
Cambridge analytic ah itself and it's
it's even it's weird to even imagine how
this has now gone even above and beyond
Robert Moeller's investigation it has
been just such a major week truly and as
we've talked about before the more that
this stuff continues to happen the
revelation that Robert molars
investigators subpoenaed documents from
Trump's business the Trump Organization
the firing of Andrew McCabe by the
ostensibly recused Attorney General Jeff
Sessions and the fact that that now is
becoming part of Robert Moeller's
investigation the erratic nature of
Trump seems to know no bounds and it
appears that nobody can control Trump
right and as we'll talk about later even
being even just direct suggestions from
his staff being ignored don't
congratulate Vladimir Putin on winning
that sham election first thing Trump
does when he gets on the phone with
Putin is congratulate congratulate him
on winning that election we will get to
all of that later but the behavior is
growing
increasingly erratic and I look forward
to hearing from people in our audience
does anybody think this is nothing send
me a tweet right I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman I would love to hear from you
about it the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership